Hello. This is 6 minute English.
from BBC Learning
English I'm Neil...
And I'm Beth.
As the world switches from fossil
fuels to renewable sources of energy,
solar panels are appearing in more
and more places and with good reason.
Yes, today, the world is generating
ten times more solar electricity
than a decade ago.
And what's more solar is the only
energy source on track to meet
the UN's 2050 net-zero targets.
But there's a problem - space.
As the rooftops in our cities
and towns get filled up
with solar panels,
finding space for them
becomes difficult. In this programme,
we'll be exploring two surprising
solar projects to build PV Panels
in all kinds
of weird and wonderful places.
And as usual, we'll be learning
some useful new vocabulary, too.
Great! But first.
I have a question for you, Beth.
Harnessing the power of the sun
is not new.
In fact, solar power dates back
over two thousand seven hundred years.
In 213 BC mirrors
were used to reflect sunlight back
on to Roman ships attacking the city of
Syracuse, causing them to catch fire.
But which ancient
Greek philosopher was responsible
for this solar heat ray
Was it a) Archimedes b) Socrates
or c) Pythagoras?
I think it was Pythagoras.
OK, Beth, I'll reveal the answer
later in the programme.
Our first surprising solar project
takes place in one of
the world's biggest car parks owned by
US supermarket giant Walmart.
Joshua Pearce, a researcher
at Western University in Ontario,
Canada wants Walmart to introduce
solar canopies in all their car parks.
A canopy is a cover fixed over something
to provide shelter or decoration.
Joshua's canopies protect customers'
cars from the sun and rain
while the solar panels fixed
on top generate electricity.
This electricity can be used by the
supermarkets or given to customers
to charge their
electric car for free.
Here's Myra Anubi presenter of BBC World
Service Programme
'People fixing the world'
discussing Joshua's idea.
Of course, if Walmart or an
equivalent retailer were to do this,
they wouldn't just be paying off their
investment in green electricity.
They would be adding hundreds of
thousands of electric charging points
across the US, which would make
switching to electric vehicles
more enticing for American drivers.
So we're starting to see
more and more of these occur.
I think in the very near future,
we're going to see
an enourmous increase.
Solar canopies provide
free charging points,
making electric cars a cheaper, more
enticing option for American drivers.
If something is enticing,
it's attractive because it
offers advantages or pleasures.
Joshua hopes we'll see more solar canopies
in the near future -  at some time very soon.
Our second surprising solar project is quite
literally out of this world.
Martin Soltau is founder of Space Solar,
a company planning to build solar panels
22,000 miles away in outer
space with no night or changing seasons,
it is believed that
solar panels in space would generate
thirteen times as much electricity
as on earth.
Martin's plans sound like science fiction
and haven't been tried out yet,
but the idea
of solar power from space
has existed since the 1960s,
as Martin explained to
BBC World Service Programme,
'People fixing the world'.
And then in really, the late sixties,
the American scientist Peter Glazier
designed the first practical,
technically practical, system.
And after that, NASA studied it on
and off right through the decades and
so it's really only in the
last six or seven years
that it's actually now
become economically feasible.
And so the whole cost of
getting things into space has tumbled
by over ninety percent.
NASA has studied the idea
of putting solar panels in space
on and off, meaning occasionally,
or from time to time
since the 1960s.
Recently, the costs of travelling to
space have tumbled - decreased quickly
and in a short time,
making Martin's idea for space solar panels
economically feasible.
If a business plan is
economically feasible,
The economic advantages achieved
are greater than the economic costs.
It seems that a good idea
is a good idea
whether it's thousands of years ago
or in the near future,
with that it is time to reveal
the answer to my question.
Yes, you asked me
which famous ancient Greek philosopher,
used the power of the sun
to destroy enemy Roman ships
in 213 BC.
I said it was
Pythagoras.
Which was...
I'm afraid to say,
the wrong answer Beth.
It was actually
Archimedes, who used parabolic
mirrors to burn
the enemy's wooden ships at Syracuse,
a trick which schoolchildren still do
today using a magnifying glass
and sun beams to make fire.
Right, let's recap the vocabulary
we've learned from this programme,
starting with 'canopy', a cover
that's fixed over an object
to shelter or decorate it.
The adjective 'enticing' means attractive
because of the advantages or benefits
it offers
'In the near future' means very soon.
The phrase 'on and off' means occasionally,
or from time to time.
If the cost or price
of something has 'tumbled', it's
decreased quickly in a short time.
And finally, if a business plan is
'economically feasible'.
The economic advantages achieved will
be greater than the economic costs.
Once again, our six minutes are up.
Goodbye, for now.
Bye!